hey there welcome back this is Simon Dev
where I code up random things of
interest things I've interests mostly to
me but maybe to you
mostly game related but really I just
like to program so if you have any ideas
for projects leave a comment below I
can't promise I'll actually do it but I
will at least consider and make an
effort
today's topic is genetic algorithms I'll
be going over those in detail and of
course I'll have some kind of pretty
pictures that I've generated along the
way let's dive in so what are they they
of course being genetic algorithms
because that's what we're talking about
today in this video anyway so what are
genetic algorithms you could think of
them as sort of a grab bag of assorted
tools that together are called genetic
algorithms this this grab bag of tools
is very very loosely modeled on
evolution so your intelligent design
people can can move along these are
inspired by evolution what do I mean by
inspired I mean that quite literally
they're simplification of the processes
that happen over the eons with evolution
so in evolution you have populations of
organisms that reproduce and survive and
thrive in given conditions and this is
what we're trying to replicate with
genetic algorithms what they do in
essence is a giant programmatic game of
warmer colder you know that game that
kids play where like so you have a ball
or a toy or something like that and you
go and hide it and the other kid puts
their hands over their eyes and they're
like they walk around and the other the
first one goes like warmer colder until
they find it kind of like I guess
another version would be like Marco Polo
in the pool hey apparently a Wikipedia
calls this hucklebuckle Beanstalk which
is the Haven even crazier name here hot
buttered beans I have no idea where that
name comes from that
that is a sweet name though and I will
go down that Wikipedia rabbit hole after
I finished recording this so back to
what they are so I said they're inspired
by evolution and what they do is they
sample a set of solutions and each
iteration they try and get a little bit
closer so going back to the biological
version you can think of a polar bear in
the Arctic and every successive
generation is better adapted to survive
in that climate so each iteration in a
genetic algorithm is trying to get a
little closer to the ideal solution and
most likely what you'll end up with is a
good solution like a good enough
solution not the best one because you
could imagine comparing it to
exhaustively searching every possible
permutation imagine for example that
you've got a function that takes one or
two variables you might be able to
exhaustively search through every
possible value for those one or two
variables but as that function gets more
complicated as it takes more variables
and the search space is larger that gets
prohibitively expensive very very fast
so with these super multi-dimensional
problems the chances of getting caught
in a local minima are pretty high and
the chances that the solution you end up
with is the global Maxima or minima are
super low like there are many many
possible good solutions and there's
probably only one perfect solution
genetic algorithms will in a reasonable
amount of time deliver a good enough
solution so how do they work like I said
grab bag of tools there's no one
specific way to implement them you
really just have a set of recommended
operators that you use and together you
call them a genetic algorithm so the
first step is to seed a random
population of solutions sort of
solutions with quotes around them
according with my fingers but I don't
have a webcam each of these being
essentially a guess at
answer next you need a way of ranking
them often this is called the fitness
function and where you go through each
member of your population and you see
how good of a solution it was and that
way you can sort everything from best to
worst after you have everything sorted
and you have all your best answers
you'll probably find that it's
especially in the first iteration that
all of them suck but a few of them will
suck just slightly less than the rest
and you'll work with those you'll select
those ones and start breeding them
together mixing and matching the
parameters to essentially create a whole
new set of guesses at the answer more
officially there are three operators to
use when breeding them together these
are called selection mutation and
crossover and selection is how you pick
which ones to breed mutation is how you
randomly permute the values and cross
over which is how you decide to mix the
parameters and these are actually quite
simple
some basic approaches would be to just
for the selection operator for example
you take the top 10% just cut off the
bottom 90% discard them and work with
the top 10% the mutation operator could
be equally simple so the mutation is
just going to randomly permute the
values a little bit so you just add a
little bit of random noise to it let's
say 1% of the range of the value and
then finally cross over and this is how
you decide to mix the parameters from
the two parents that you're breeding
together and simple approach it so that
would be to just randomly take values
from each one and finally once you've
done all that take all the new solutions
that you have or guesses and repeat
these steps and eventually you'll end up
with a pretty good answer like I said
probably not the best answer that you
can possibly have but a pretty decent
one so this has been all a bit academic
let's step through an actual example
here so here's a crazy obstacle course
that clearly I I drew myself there's a
big wall there and then I've got a
vote with maybe Gators in there I don't
know piranhas who knows and then at a
t-rex because you know this is this is
how I imagine what Tough Mudder would be
like so here at the start line you've
got your genetically engineered running
mutants or whatever they are and they're
all prepped to go now at this point it's
hard to know who's really going to excel
at this race it's the guy with the
Bigfoot is the guy with the oversized
head
who knows there's even one with like
giant arms and almost no feet we make
them race and some finish some don't
some get eaten by the t-rex or they
drown in the moat or they don't even
make it over the wall or who knows what
happened to them so now in this in this
example we're gonna take the top three
two of them finished one got really
close to the finish line for whatever
reason these three were better suited
than the rest for excelling at this
specific race and so we're gonna start
mixing and matching traits between them
and voila now you've got this totally
new set of runners a few of them have a
Bigfoot now a bunch of them have the big
head thing going on
one of them has both big head and
Bigfoot and we'll repeat this over and
over and over again until we're
satisfied that the set of runners that
we have is pretty good so let's see this
in action for real I went and downloaded
a few random images from the web and
I'll SiC my genetic algorithm
implementation on them and let's see how
this turns out
[Music]